I always use this example of Conor
McGregor he got two cracks at the
featherweight Championship because he
fought Chad Mendes as a step in and he
got the inim belt and then he did Aldo
in 13 seconds this press dude in an
interview asked what are you going to do
differently this time that you didn't do
last time when he's about to fight Aldo
and he says I'm going to take it all in
because he was so preoccupied fearful in
the zone and doing the things that
facilitated his performance that he
didn't actually get to experience what
he was going through there's this great
photo of him stood on stage at the
ceremonial weigh-in or it might have
even been before the ceremonial weigh-in
it might have been the actual one you
got that tattoo running up his back and
it's just him with his hands out like
this 40,000 people in front of them just
everyone stood up and it's electric
right it's Conor McGregor Peak Sant
artist of War just stood there with his
hands out and he wasn't there for it his
mind wasn't there as he was experiencing
one of the most profound moments of his
entire life but he got a second crack